[Music]
well with all the major world events
currently unfolding you may have missed
this story even though it has been
dutifully reported by all of our
major media outlets as nbc tells us the
singer lizzo has tearfully called out
fat phobic and racist hate directed
towards her newsweek buffing to post the
la times daily beast many other sources
have issued their own reports on this
subject apparently in a recent instagram
live video lizzo began crying about the
internet trolls who are mean to her
accuse them of racism and fat phobia and
complained about the deep impact that
these that these random anonymous
accounts have had on her self-esteem now
i'm sure you already agree that this was
of course a newsworthy event
but uh here's a little bit of that video
just so you can fully appreciate the
scope and implication of this issue here
it is
i have people who have something
something mean to say about you
and for the most part it doesn't hurt my
feelings
i don't care
i just think when
i'm working this hard my my tolerance
gets lower
my patience is lower i'm more sensitive
and it gets to me
you know we're meant to feel quite bad
for lizzo in fact we've been sternly
instructed to feel bad for her a post on
jezebel says that her tears are so pure
her heartache is so deep and profound
that we quote don't deserve lizzo's
tears
i don't really know what that means but
i'm sure it meant something to the
person who wrote it a writer for
refinery29 explains that quote lizzo's
joy her steadfast belief and her right
to exist and fully occupy spaces upsets
people who bought into the white
supremacist lie that these things black
bodies and radical beliefs must shrink
lizzo is beautiful well-resourced and
has millions of fans listening to her
reclaim her space
once again that doesn't appear to really
mean anything
is there a white supremacist conspiracy
to shrink black bodies
has rick moranis turned into a neo-nazi
and begun using his powers for evil i'm
not sure but the point we're supposed to
take away from this is that um
yes that was a honey i shrunk the kids
reference kids you might you're too
young for that
um
lizzo is is a victim that's the point
he's she is an injured precious flower
and this is all a major problem for the
world actually her tearful complaints
about mean internet comments are sort of
interesting when you compare them to the
song she just released called rumors now
in the video for that song she twerks in
a skin-tight suit while boasting that
her body is goals meaning that her body
is so beautiful that other people want
to look just like her you know they have
a goal to look just like her and she
brags about walking around with quote
her ass hanging out
now i know that you're hoping
desperately that i will let you see and
hear all of this for yourself and you're
in luck because here it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
baby take a look around if you thought
that i
was hanging out just
[Music]
what they do
so there you go
unironically i will say that the song is
powerful and i don't mean powerful in
the sense that the odor from an
overflowing garbage can baking in the
sun is powerful though it is powerful in
that sense as well and there's no doubt
that it is a powerfully awful garbage
song and part of the music industry's
increasingly successful plot to make
everybody dumber but when i say powerful
i mean really that there are some
important lessons we can learn from all
of this the first is that
if you don't want people
making comments about your body
don't run around half naked
while insisting that everybody look at
your body okay it's a fact of life that
if you purposefully put an intimate
aspect of yourself on display to the
world you are going to hear the world's
opinions about it don't want the world's
opinions keep it to yourself
you might say that the world should have
better manners
you know and maybe maybe it should but
it doesn't and at a certain point you
need to start operating within reality
as it is actually constructed also
manners run both ways it is bad manners
to walk around with your quote ass
hanging out in lizzo's words and in fact
when you do that
and you call attention to it
and you say hey everybody look my ass is
hanging out the people who have been
subjected to that site are i would say
not only within their rights but within
the bounds of proper etiquette to say
something like wow gross can you please
stop that the idea that people have
today is that they should have the right
to flaunt themselves their bodies their
personal lives every personal detail
about them revealing every crack and
crevice of themselves to the public if
you'll pardon the phrase and that they
should also get to determine how the
public reacts to that ghastly spectacle
but it doesn't work that way
and again this is not only about showing
off your body these days people like to
show off many other things all of the
most personally intimate details about
them and then become deeply traumatized
when strangers honestly react to it
they want us to know their business
but also to stay out of their business
it is schizophrenic and ridiculous
also there's something else
note how lizzo fronts as this confident
body positive boisterous bold
self-esteem warrior and yet in reality
breaks down in tears because a few
random people on the internet insulted
her
i mean lizzo is roundly praised almost
everywhere by almost everyone she's rich
and famous beloved highly acclaimed
she's won awards she's run she's won
commendations of all kinds the entire
media is ready to print headlines
congratulating her or consoling her
whatever she needs
she lives in this echo chamber of
adulation and yet crumbles if the
slightest criticism leaks through the
cracks
now some of us like yours truly are also
very harshly judged and criticized on
the internet and yet are certainly not
engulfed in flattery nearly to the same
extent and
we don't cry over mean comments
least of all would we cry publicly live
streaming it for the world to see
so what's going on here
well this is more evidence of what
should already be obvious
the body positivity stuff
the self-esteem on steroids stuff the
look at me i'm so beautiful and awesome
posturing that you get from pop stars
and from normal people also in this
culture these days it's all an act it's
all a form of overcompensation a way to
disguise their crippling insecurities
people don't go around showing off their
bodies flaunting themselves talking
about how great and amazing and
beautiful they are if they are actually
confident in themselves
confident people
wear normal clothing and go about their
day
they are body positive in the sense that
they don't spend an exorbitant amount of
time thinking about their bodies
they are not immersed in thoughts about
their own bodies
and they certainly don't need you to
think about their bodies
so what we call body positivity is
actually body affirmation the people who
constantly announce to the world that
they're body positive are actually
saying that they need affirmation they
need you to notice them and then notice
their bodies and respond in a certain
way
they say they don't care they don't care
about anybody's opinion but but
literally the exact opposite is true
there is nothing they value more than
everybody's opinion
they live for your approval they need it
like they need air and water
but putting lizzo's specific case aside
for a moment
i think it's interesting to think about
how we got to this point where so many
people are so totally dependent upon
public affirmation and approval
we've talked about that problem quite a
bit
how do we get here why is it like this
i think one obvious culprit is the
internet you know as most kids grow up
on the internet
are raised by the internet in many ways
they become conditioned to this
environment where everything you do and
say is a public spectacle and you
receive an immediate judgment from your
audience
you do something say something post
something and your audience responds
right away with either applause or
affirmation
jeers or disapproval thumbs up or thumbs
down nice comments or mean comments
jerry seinfeld once said that when he's
on the stage he gets a performance
review every 30 seconds because the
crowd laughs at the joke or not
and so it's different from other you
know kinds of jobs where you get a
performance review every month or
whatever
and when you're on the stage it's like
it's an immediate thing
the feedback is also blunt right
well now everybody is on a stage of
sorts our kids grow up on one
where they receive those rapid fire
performance reviews every hour of every
day they become conditioned to depend on
those reviews always seeking the
dopamine hit that comes with a positive
evaluation
and because they live for positive
feedback their greatest fear is
criticism negative feedback
criticism starts to feel almost like a
almost like a physical danger something
that threatens to undermine their very
existence
now if this sounds like a horrible way
to condition children
and like a recipe for a society full of
fragile non-functioning crybabies well
welcome to america circa 2021
lizzo is the poster child for everything
that has just been described which
explains her popularity but also
explains why she is today finally
canceled
again i think i think this is like the
third time
hasn't set in yet we'll keep going
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated